one of Hollywood's dystopian dramas has
been affected by a real-life pandemic a
quiet place part zoo the long-awaited
sequel to director John Krasinski's
hugely successful horror debut has been
delayed due to growing concerns over the
covert 19 outbreak sweeping the globe
this news comes to us courtesy of the
director himself who confirmed on social
media that the second film in the quiet
place universe at a Stowe pian world in
which monsters attack anyone who makes
the slightest sound will be delayed from
its international March 18th opening
beyond that worldwide release the flick
was also slated for a march 19th release
in the United Kingdom and the March 20th
opening in North America plenty of films
have seen their release dates delayed
their production halted or suspended all
that normal journey to theaters
otherwise disrupted by covert 19 a
mutation of the corona virus that has
proven lethal to more vulnerable
portions of the population and which has
a higher rate of serious cases than the
seasonal flu however in the wake of
countries like Italy pushing its
citizens to enter a state of quarantine
which prohibits its citizens from
attending public gatherings or spending
time in crowded places as well as
outbreaks within the United States the
entertainment industry is paying
attention the plots of acquire plates
parts who finds Everland played by
Christine Sookie's real-life wife Emily
Blunt trying to survive with her
children in the aftermath of her
husband's death in the first film the
latest seemingly the last minute a new
release date for the movie was not
immediately announced Paramount Pictures
a studio behind the quiet place sequel
released a statement about the film's
delay after much consideration and in
light of the ongoing and developing
situation concerning coronavirus and
restrictions on global travel and public
gatherings Paramount Pictures will be
moving the worldwide release of a quiet
place part 2 we believe in and support
the theatrical experience and we look
forward to bringing this film to
audiences this year once we have a
better understanding of the impact of
this pandemic on the globe or theatrical
marketplace Krasinski is back in the
director's chair for the second
installment and he also appears in the
narrative mrs. karat sadly in flashbacks
in his statement about the film's to lay
on Instagram he kept things positive
writing one of the things I'm most proud
of is that people have said our movie
is one you have to see all together well
due to the ever-changing circumstances
of what's going on in the world around
us
now it's clearly not the right time to
do that as insanely excited as we are
for all of you to see this movie I'm
gonna wait to release the film till we
can or see it together so here's to our
group a movie date see you soon
it's safe to assume that the team behind
the quiet place part 2 didn't want to
take such a drastic measure when it came
to the film's release
but with concerns over public safety
hitting a frightening high it does seem
like they're made the responsible choice
as the outbreak of kovat 19 continues
across the world the United States is
entering a potential state of emergency
while other countries are finding
themselves on various forms of lockdown
to prevent any further potentially fatal
spread unsurprisingly the film industry
has been hit hard with tons of films
facing filming delays and halted
releases the newest James Bond film no
time to die
was one of the first films Abbott's
release date affected by the crisis as
covert 19 spread Daniel Craig's final
outing as double oh seven was delayed by
a whopping 8 months getting a new
November at least eight instead of its
original April premiere as the United
States faced its own emerging cope in 19
cases when the virus spread outside of
Europe and Asia new concerns grew
affecting a number of other projects as
well between filming delays on the next
Mission Impossible movie a temporary
hold on production on the CW's Riverdale
and the next Fast and Furious film
getting delayed for an entire year
studios are sparing no effort to keep
people safe as the pandemic sets in stay
safe out there
we hope to see you at the movies when
this all blows over check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]